okay so this you'll see a lot of this
and um that's just like a corruption
of the practice like
yoga studio yoga is a corruption
okay i need to have
a single pivot point when i turn
anything more than that causes
instability in the turn when pressure is
placed upon it
so in this drill
he's got pressure on my two corners
okay and i'm going to
do a yin movement
take the turning aspect establish a
single pivot point
on my front foot
so you're going to feel a few things if
you'll if you can't get all your weight
onto the single pivot point you won't be
able to turn
okay so i have to get
my weight you see how i'm shifting it
forward
as the turn is going in essence i'm
going around
i'm going around this energy here
this one is yielding
so i have to shift weight on the front
foot
and i complete the deviation
[Music]
by shifting this brings this shoulder
all completely off the line of attack
and i'm completely off this line of this
half
okay here can't go forward that would be
a clash
i'm going to go around it in this
turning
establishing a single pivot point
so i am turning
but with the single pivot point
[Music]
all my weight's on that foot okay here
we go
okay so uh push you're gonna be here all
day
push push push you're gonna be here all
day all right
just like just it's just like this troll
he's just grounding the back foot
so he's over here he's just grounding
the back foot i'm not gonna go anywhere
okay so
i don't want you to think when when
you're doing this drill though that
you're doing that do you get it the guy
is pushing so hard on you
that uh if you get some hip rotation
you start to take away his vector
into the back you see the back foot you
see that when you pay attention
i never shift forward i'm just turning
here okay
um so it's this is not
your your your kind of thing where
you're using
e even an ik adhesion you're not you're
not doing that
okay um i'm
i'm literally it's just the
non-contestation of
jitsu so here's here's that angle
it's almost the opposite because to keep
this i have to
drive that into him so i have to keep
that stuck
what i'm trying to do is go around
around it do you see that
so not not into him and move him
uh but release release and start to go
around it
okay so the reason we have on the four
corners
is when you have a gooey center
um you're going to realize oh that's
probably why i do that double pivot
point
is i can't i can't turn as a unit okay
i don't know how to lock a relationship
between my hips and my shoulders
so i'm not turning him
i'm getting completely out of the way of
his energy
so let's let's say he's he's now coming
in with that same energy
boom
he's going that's what i'm doing
see i'm making miss because i'm going
around this
and going around shift
and around
here shift and round
non contestation shift
and round
shift
[Music]
okay let's try to go to one okay so we
have many videos on
uh umiyashi tenkanashi
and it explains the in and the young of
the movements right
but uh and many videos on double
pivot points versus single pivot points
so
what we're doing is if i if i'm doing
tai no henko
it's this part there
where most will double pivot
their line of gravity is between their
two feet
but without the deviation because that's
the beauty of
this if you watch my line of gravity
it's going to move to the left as if i
took a step
so i'm going around
and to the outside
around this as i turn my body's turning
and going forward and to the outside of
his body
without having to take the step
[Music]
and it's the same beginner drill we do
right
all right i'm just using it now
around this pressure without moving
push hard oh we're over here all day
so one way you'll see again it's always
a test correct form
works better under more intensity
so push really hard and he becomes way
more slippery push a little
there's a lot more drag here because a
lot of the energy is leaking out
but you can still do it hard
ground boom on the other foot okay
let's try it okay
so uh when i shift my weight
onto the front leg
i'm going i'm going outside of his
energy
as i do in the yin rotation so
what ends up happening is you'll see
that there
becomes this oblique angle which right
here
i have that angle of incidence
i'm going to do non-cos contestation by
getting the oblique
if you start turning here you're going
to double pivot
and he's going to find a ledge okay
you want to keep shifting keep shifting
and turn single pivot point
so you see i'm pushing into him
i want to go around that
so he comes forward but now when you get
here
you start going goddamn and you start
turning but you're
[Music]
creating that ledge for him so once you
get
this keep going forward
take all your weight off of the other
leg okay
don't get greedy and go
slip the first part and now i'm turning
you're double pivoting that's why he
gets you again
you have to you have to keep the
slipperyness
going so you get in this corner
if you pay attention i'm going to get
behind him
so one this is not enough
two and then here i am again which is
weird
okay you're always in this corner so
don't turn in front of him
which was you see i'm going to turn in
front of him you got to get behind him
boom when you do the turn okay try it
again
okay so uh now the guy's coming in boom
and i'm going to do the same thing
and again the the harder he comes in
if i'm doing it correctly the easier it
is
so
okay